dans le ciel de carquif dépannage de
fumée la seconde ville du crâne devenue
la cible principale de l'armée russe
méthodiquement l'aviation largue ces
bombes sur les immeubles résidentiels
ou abritant des institutions comme
celui-ci le siège de la police en proie
aux flammes impossible pour la
population de trouver du répit épuisée
cette jeune femme témoigne
[Musique]
pour nous
tout d'abord parce que à 22h on a
entendu un bruit fort puis le ciel est
devenu rouge
un site vers minuit on allait déjà au
lit et on a entendu des
tirs des sons de bataille de rue
des batailles de rue
car des troupes aéroports ont débarqué
dans la ville indique l'armée
ukrainienne
avant c'était des bombardements avec des
avions avec l'artillerie et donc des
parachutistes aussi du nouveau les
combats de rue oui ça va être plus
brutal sur cette carte en rouge les
zones contrôlées par les troupes russes
en dehors de karkyfles les combats les
plus acharnés se déroulent dans le Sud
notamment à Mario Paul et Terson querson
un port stratégique sur ces images
tournées il y a quelques jours l'armée
ukrainienne avait déjà perdu le contrôle
des ponts et des accès elle aura encore
perdu du terrain selon les Russes